starbucks isn't doing that great in fact
it's down 40 year-to-date and it's
currently the 474th worst performing
stock in the s p 500. this correlates to
a total market cap loss of 66.4
billion dollars given how the overall
market is doing though i bet a lot of
you guys aren't even surprised the
nasdaq and russell 2000 are officially
in bear markets and the s p 500 is
teetering between correction and bear
market territory but while it's easy to
just write off starbucks sell-off as a
result of a weak market there's actually
a lot of background factors that are
prompting this sell-off and if you don't
believe me just take a look at this
last month the retired father of
starbucks howard schultz returned
starbucks to change the direction of the
company this isn't the first time howard
is leaving retirement to run starbucks
either
back in 2008 during the height of the
financial recession howard returned
starbucks as ceo and he led the company
up until 2017. during this time period
starbucks stock grew an impressive at
17x from the 2008 bottom but the company
hasn't done all that much since howard
left in fact the stock is almost back to
the same price that you left it at this
has caused many investors to question if
anybody can run starbucks other than
howard but before we get into that we
have to look into whether howard can
even save starbucks again in the first
place so what even happened to starbucks
one of the top factors driving down
starbucks is worldwide shortages in
almost everything starting with labor if
you haven't heard already a significant
number of employees especially in the us
have been quitting their jobs over the
past few years
in fact in 2021 47 million americans
voluntarily quit their jobs and if you
didn't notice that's literally
one-fourth of the entire u.s labor force
given that the unemployment rate isn't
skyrocketing though it's clear that
these guys aren't just leaving the
corporate world altogether
rather they're switching over to
companies and jobs where they feel more
respected and appreciated naturally you
would think that compensation plays a
big factor in this decision as well but
this is actually not the case
in fact dissatisfaction with one's
salary does not even rank in the top 10
reasons that people are leaving their
jobs salary dissatisfaction actually
comes in at rank 16. some of the reasons
that people are really switching jobs is
a toxic corporate culture and
underappreciated work and there's no
question that these issues are
especially prevalent within service
oriented industries like starbucks this
trend has made it extremely difficult
for starbucks to fill positions and keep
them filled and it's not just a case of
oh we're missing a cashier or a barista
today no starbucks is literally missing
half of their workforce you see when the
pandemic hit starbucks laid off the vast
majority of their employees their
employee account fell from 349 000
employees to 138 000 employees meanwhile
the number of stores starbucks was
operating never went down it actually
kept going up
we don't yet know how many of these
positions starbucks has filled since
last september but i think it's pretty
safe to assume that it's not the full
211 000 positions this means that the
remaining employees are having to do
even more work which is just further
motivating them to switch jobs the
staffing shortage has actually gotten so
bad that some starbucks locations have
started reducing store hours and as a
business that's usually the last thing
you want to do especially if there's
sufficient demand aside from facing a
severe staffing shortage starbucks is
also having to deal with the supply
shortage if you go to your local
starbucks it's more than likely that at
least a few of the menu items are
unavailable due to a lack of ingredients
some of the hardest hit ingredients
include oat milk flavored syrups and tea
bags but the shortage also extends to
some of starbucks most popular offerings
as well
some locations don't even have
frappuccino mix or breakfast sandwiches
and just a few months ago the entire
region of upstate new york ran out of
mocha so not only are starbucks
employees having to do more work but
they're also having to constantly deal
with customers that are upset that they
can't even get what they came for and
the longer the shortages keep up it's
just gonna become harder and harder for
starbucks to recover
the supply shortage isn't the only
reason that customers are upset either
another issue that is driving up
customer dissatisfaction is rising
prices now it's no secret that starbucks
is already a premium brand with
expensive offerings many people have
looked past these prices for years due
to convenience and taste however as
starbucks continues to raise prices it's
becoming harder and harder for customers
to justify going to starbucks
the worst part is that this is not
something that starbucks even has
control over prices across the board are
simply skyrocketing and they have to
raise prices to keep up for example the
price of coffee has doubled since 2019
from 100 a pound to over 200 per pound
similarly i'm sure that all of the
equipment that starbucks locations along
with their cups spoons and straws have
also risen in price due to
out-of-control inflation and on top of
all of this starbucks is having to raise
wages to retain the employees that they
do have last october they committed to
increasing minimum wage across the
country to 15 per hour now i'm not
trying to argue whether such wage hikes
are justified or not but one thing
that's certain is that someone has to
pay for these higher wages and more
times than not that someone is the
customer meanwhile from the customer's
perspective it's not just starbucks
where they're having to spend more money
over the past year the cost of living
has skyrocketed everything from gas and
energy bills to grocery and housing
costs have gone to the moon while wages
haven't and there's only so many price
increases that consumers can afford
before they start to decrease their
consumption necessities like gas and the
groceries aren't something you can avoid
but something you can avoid is
overpriced starbucks coffee and as
inflation and continues to remain high
we'll likely just see more and more
people cut back on such purchases
something else that's also leading to
customer and employee dissatisfaction in
starbuck's mobile slash online order
system embracing a mobile order system
was a no-brainer during the pandemic but
long term it seems to have caused more
headaches than solutions here's the
thing when people come to the store and
order in person there's a natural limit
to how long the line will get i mean if
there's already 20 people in line the
people who come after are more likely to
just skip starbucks for the day
but when a significant number of people
are ordering online and there's a long
line at the store fulfilling all these
orders quickly becomes overwhelming
especially during rush hours with a
staffing shortage and when these online
customers show up at the store they're
often upset that their order isn't ready
yet something else to note is that when
people order online they're way more
likely to make more complex orders
because it's easier to click buttons
than to verbally communicate such an
order this has made fulfilling online
orders more time consuming which just
just made it even harder to keep up with
rush hour demand to make things worse
their online system often doesn't
reflect missing ingredients meaning that
customers are often allowed to put in
orders that can't be made this leaves
the employees with two options either
they can inform the customer that their
order can't be completed when they show
up at the store which is probably not
the most fun thing to do or they can
substitute the missing ingredient with
an alternative that is available but
this doesn't necessarily lead to the
happiest of customers either the
straightforward solution to this
conundrum is for starbucks to revamp
their online system and implement two
features
first of all their online system should
limit orders to a manageable volume and
secondly their online system should
accurately represent shortages
if they don't revamp their online system
we'll likely just continue to see more
misunderstandings between customers and
employees causing starbucks to lose
customers over the long term
while all of the factors that we've
discussed so far are definitely weighing
down on starbucks business likely the
biggest reason behind howard's return is
starbucks employees unionizing for
service-based businesses with hundreds
of thousands of minimum wage workers
unions are often their biggest fear
here's the thing while starbucks charges
a ridiculous amount for their beverages
they don't actually take that much of it
to the bottom line historically
starbucks net margin has hovered at just
under 15 percent and while this is a
solid amount for a restaurant business
this doesn't give them much leeway in
terms of raising wages
so starbucks and other low margin
companies like amazon are extremely
anti-union but despite their attempts to
stifle unions we've seen starbucks
employees put up quite a fight over the
past year for example remember how
starbucks committed to increasing their
minimum wage to 15 per hour well this
was a last-ditch effort to try to stifle
union participation before they hiked
wages they were attempting to terminate
every union member they could find they
even sent managers to starbucks
locations to try to dissuade union
participation and it looks like
starbucks is simply doubling down on
crushing unions
at the beginning of may howard announced
a set of races that will only benefit
non-unionized workers and he justified
this decision with likely the most
garbage reason you have ever heard
howard suggested that he couldn't raise
wages for unionized workers because that
would be imposing new wages without the
union's approval starbucks workers
united has fired back by filing charges
against howard for discriminating
against union workers
this is still a very fluid situation so
we'll have to wait and see how this
battle plays out but honestly i think
howard's best choice is to simply give
in to the unions here's the thing howard
can play this game as much as he wants
and he might even win against the unions
but i think howard's victory would
actually be a loss for starbucks over
the years starbucks has maintained a
pretty respectable image when it comes
to employee benefits and treatment but
pushing vigorously against unions can
easily destroy that image and i don't
think that's in starbucks best interest
given that this is the primary reason
that howard has returned though i
suspect that this is going to be a
bloody battle
at the end of the day starbucks is a
mess both internally and externally
they're plagued with staff and supply
shortages while having to deal with
insane inflation and bad software which
is leading to pretty unhappy customers
on top of this starbucks is ferociously
fighting against internal unionization
efforts which have thus far proven quite
successful howard returning to starbucks
simply enunciates how critical the
situation is and unfortunately there is
no easy solution if howard gives into
the union starbucks will likely have to
deal with even higher operating expenses
which will just make it even harder for
them to retain customers on the other
hand if howard doesn't give in starbucks
will not only continue to face a
staffing shortage but they'll probably
tarnish their reputation
and in my opinion their long-term
reputation is worth a lot more than
short-term profits but with that being
said if anyone can get starbucks back on
track it's howard so we'll have to wait
and see what he does do you guys believe
howard can turn starbucks around comment
that down below
also drop a like if you think starbucks
is overrated and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch your videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one